luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to the
leia hill pen show we are live from mexico which
is super exciting so my background's a little
bit different today okay so this is powered by
icon plus capsule the vc firm sponsored by
blockfi luno and we're gonna jump straight
into this because i have a really really exciting
guest today so she's a best-selling author
the ceo of invest diva which maybe gives
it away a little bit she's been featured
in forbes [ __ ] time cnn it is kiana daniel
kiana how are you i am doing well how are you
i'm good thank you it's so great to meet you
i've been following you for a really long
time and i absolutely love the work that you do
it's absolutely brilliant super excited to be on
so for those that don't know you because i
know you're predominantly in the traditional
financial space obviously you're involved in
crypto as well but obviously i have quite a
more of a crypto audience so for those that
don't know you please can you just give us
a background and tell us what you do yeah
so basically the invest eva movement's goal
is to help parents actually take control of
their financial future and it is interesting
that i got into cryptocurrency because they were
they asked me to write this book cryptocurrency
for dummies and then i became at least
in the eyes of the media the crypto lady
but actually what we do is a little bit much
much much deeper we talk about personal finance
wealth creation like actually creating this
ecosystem of wealth where you're making more
money and then your money is making more money and
um through ownership and then investing and then
diversifying obviously with crypto and stocks
and whatever assets that are suitable to you
and your tolerance so that is what the investiva
movement is actually about it's not just crypto
although i love crypto it's one of not the biggest
but it's a very big portion of my portfolio
so really just financial liberty just getting to
the crux of it how to build long lasting wealth
how to build generational wealth is our goal so
how do we compound our compound faster because
of course if you're just investing you're you're
compounding but it's not fast enough so if you
are just investing 50 bucks per month you get two
million dollars in 65 years which is great but
it's not fast we want to make money fast and then
you want to do it without it being an mlm or a
ponzi scheme so basically i did it and i'm like oh
my gosh this actually works and now i teach how to
do that to other people so before we get into all
of that and understanding exactly how you build
that generational wealth fast not like an mlm but
fast and in a good way i'd love to know a little
bit more about you you're are you iranian or
your parents are from iran what's your backstory
yeah so i'm fully iranian persian if you
want to be classy about it and not like
fully virgin jewish i want to raise actually
i was there until i was 18 and then i went to
japan i was there for seven years and i actually
just came to america 10 years ago so english
i mispronounced something please don't hate on
me the other day i must pronounce the states
american state and like i got so much hit i'm
like oh my gosh it's just one word so it was my
third language this play oh i didn't realize that
i didn't realize like you'd only just gone to the
states 10 years ago that's i didn't know that
so how how is it different than you know when
it comes to finance as a woman building you know
this kind of this intellect and this knowledge
and these skill sets how is that different
did you struggle in iran with that
so both in iran and japan money as a taboo
topic and i've realized also it is in
every other part of the world really in
america a little bit less getting better but
money is just a topic you don't want to
talk about you want to pretend that you
don't care about money and so that's that was my
upbringing i had this what i call the welfare diva
money mindset that you don't want to talk about
money you don't want to even work for money money
doesn't buy your happiness so that was the mindset
and in japan it was a huge and i got a little bit
um uh bold with it and i was like talking
about money and importance of money actually
in japan when i was on a tv show in japan
and people are like oh my god who's this girl
you want well i was like like they called me
like the bombastic bomb girl or something like
that they gave me this nickname because i'm
like iranian girl talking about money but um
and it has been i've been trying to get my money
mindset right it has been a work in progress it
wasn't like coming to america and bam i got my my
survive it wasn't i i came to america i started
working on wall street thought i hadn't had it all
and then i lost everything again i was about like
i actually lived in a welfare house and it was um
it was tough times and then again rebuilding and
rebuilding and rebuilding this idea of actually
what money really is and how it can help you and
other people and your children your grandchildren
so um america has been great in a sense that um
i feel like it is okay to stand out so in japan
it is not okay to stand out like they will like
literally not let you stand out um and they it's
very different culture so america is great in that
sense um what was shocking to me was that both
america and japan had this male female wheels
which is surprising because you would think
that iran which is like the oppressive
country would be very very hard on women
but i grew up not thinking that math
or anything stem is like well okay and um i i
went on engineering school without even even
though i wasn't really good at math because
it was like okay it was like it's going
taking history in college it wasn't like
something like a big deal and then i went
to japan i was the only girl in my class like
what where are the other girls and then i went to
on wall street i'm the only girl in the team like
what so then i was like wow the culture about this
there was a male dominated field culture
here which was very very interesting
that is really interesting that you wouldn't
know that coming from iran because a lot of the
time the media sort of portrays a certain picture
which isn't necessarily true and you often hear
you know people living in those countries that
sort of say well actually that's not how it is um
so that's interesting so you were building a lot
um struggled a little bit but building a lot so
how did you then stumble across money and wanting
to build something and you know how did you become
financially litter basically so the journey began
in 2008 when the markets crashed and i was a
struggling engineer trying to find a job and i'm i
really wasn't good at it so um but i had i was on
this tv show that i would talk about like social
issues and stuff like that and um on the tv show i
learned that the markets are crashing i had
no idea what the markets are i didn't know
what crashing financial crisis even mean but
they said hey okay so the markets are crashing
that means the fed is printing money that means
all the i mean all the central banks have affected
i mean also the japanese central bank and that
means that there's inflation it was like what's
inflation they're like okay that means that
the value of your cash is going down and the
way to compound and combat it is to invest
it i'm like wow that's cool and then that's
really cool i accidentally got into the forex
market because i understood like the exchange
rates because i was in japan i had a japanese
yen i have like i was from so as a foreigner i
understood what foreign exchange means yeah
friends is like hey yeah you can like make money
on this u.s dollar downfall like wow okay so again
accidentally i made like 10 thousand bucks in a
month this is so cool and yeah that's where it
really ignited that passionate need to understand
what it's all about and it got me to come to
wall street and learning more about it and then
the rest is history i totally understand the
idea of living in a foreign country and then
realizing how fx works i was living in malta they
used the euro and i was getting paid in pounds and
i was getting paid in euros and i was like oh i've
just made money now just because of the fx rate
and that also was quite interesting for me as well
so yeah you really have to be there um to i guess
to trigger to trigger that sort of like emotional
kind of interest in it um so generational wealth
that is something that we all want if you could
give us you know three tips i know that's hard i
know it's a little bit unfair you can give us
five if you want to give us five but one like
the main tips to building generational wealth so
i mean the thing is it's the cliche it really is
it is it's the cliche so what has worked for me
i call this the zen wealth generator and it has
actually three points point number one invest
in yourself so that you can increase your income
two increase your income so have multiple revenue
streams and point number three invest the money
that you made so invest in yourself increase
your income and invest in the financial markets
and so what what a lot of people just don't
get is that okay they only want to get like
increase their income or they only want to become
entrepreneurs so they go and become introverted
and then the stats are shocking that um
oh my gosh what was this um 90 of ceos are
three paychecks away from going bankrupt it's like
crazy wow that is crazy uh i'll don't quote me on
the exact number but it's like a crazy stats and
then you have day traders and investors who are
doing okay but again it's not fast enough and then
day traders again so they traders they lose money
i don't know if you agree with that but they
do i did it doesn't work it's not like the
time that you invest in day trading in my opinion
it absolutely is not worth the return because you
have to be stuck to your screen all day and you
have to like be just chasing the speculations
all the things for me what really really worked
was creating a business that works and creating
multiple revenue streams from there so i have like
multiple books i make money through my affiliate
partnerships and then everything builds upon each
other so it's compounding on that end and then
invest that money so this way you're putting
more and more money into investment accounts and
everything is compounding at this exponential
return so i've given you an example is that
when i was just investing at the beginning my
investing strategy is pretty good i'm actually
a good investor so like uh i i started out
with 500 bucks when i got fired from my job and
i did go fire i started with 500 bucks and in
three years i turned that 500 bucks into 50 000
which is a great return it's a great return but
fifty thousand dollars barely pays for like a
down payment of a decent it doesn't it does not in
america doesn't right so um and but at that return
if i had putting five hundred thousand dollars
in at that return that would have been 50 million
dollars right yeah of course i was contributing to
that so i was contributing 500 bucks per month you
contribute and then the return is crazy and then
it compounds like crazy and then once i figured
out a business that can generate passive income
it's not on mlm but it's not a lot yeah it's
just like an online business is like this crazy
thing that is really working for a lot of people
and then combining that with investing is what
has really made me stand out so my entrepreneur
peers they are making money they would make a
million dollars in a year but they're bankrupt
and then my investing peers they're just
like struggling to like they trade and
like make the money and they're hoping
for bitcoin to go up and it's all great
but it's not like happening fast enough whereas
for me i made my first million through my business
less than a year ago i just
want to show you like how crazy
fast it suddenly became i started out 10 years ago
then less than a year ago i made my first million
net that was gross profit and the net
profit was probably like 500 bucks
less than a year ago and now today my portfolio
is four million dollars wow and i like every
month i'm like oh my gosh this is crazy this
is january my portfolio was like a million
and then march it was like my half and then july
it was 2 million and now it's formally i'm like
oh my gosh the compounding is just becoming
bigger and bigger and like the impact is just
so like oh my god and and this is and this
is specifically from compound interest or
is this from your business class is your
investing come on business is making money
and now i have a team of 15 people i'm
spending five thousand dollars per day on
ads like i'm i have expenses yeah my nerve
friends who are in the same boat they are
either break even or barely like having some kind
of significant uh portfolio but for me it has been
crazy compounding not compound ingress i'm
investing in cryptocurrencies i'm investing
in stock market like all the things like i
get all the money that i make for my business
and i dump it in the in my portfolio with my
strategy and it's just compounding like crazy
so so in terms of the traditional stock
market sorry about that something in my
throat here so in times of the traditional
stock market how do you pick your stocks then
so it's actually so i've made it
simpler and simpler simpler over time
because um i used to um you know it's hard to
it's hard if you are paying attention to the media
yes so when it comes to investing actually when
it comes to anything simplifying is key so once i
switched from trying to find the next best
thing to investing in what i actually know
first of all my emotions were like i became more
sane i stopped checking my boyfriend seconds i
stopped listening to the news i'm on the news
but i don't listen to the news which is weird
and then uh it has helped immensely so how i
choose my stocks uh my portfolio has about 200
shares which is great stocks which is crazy but my
main my main like my biggest chunks are the stuff
that i personally use and spend the most money on
like the companies that i spend the most money on
says like superior go to go to my credit card
like okay what are the companies that i spend
the most money on of course facebook because
i spend like five thousand dollars for diana
no matter like where you stand with them
like oh my gosh is this good is it bad
but for me i'm like so facebook's not the best
example because i also don't like how they are
controlling people but i spend
a lot of money and i have power
um and like amazon whatever that is you're you're
spending money money like my husband is a gamer so
he spends money on nvidia and amd and stuff
like that so and we have tesla and like all
all the things that i'm actually a customer of
those are my biggest chunks and then from there
uh because i have a mastermind and our inner
circle so we mastermind what are my students
familiar with and we talk about their experience
with the companies so um that is like the layers
and then i get excited about what they're excited
about that's why i have like 200 different stocks
in my portfolio which is not recommended uh
but it's been working out well for us because
then when the market gets choppy you don't get
super emotional and make it that mistake right
so it's literally where you actually see value
where you spend your money so in terms of
you mention you know emotions take me through
some of the biggest mistakes people make when
it comes to investing oh my gosh so listening
to the nose is the biggest one uh falling for
the hypo fomo and it's you can't help it unless
you're like super secure and that's why that's why
like people don't understand the importance
of being confident in your choice until
s-h-i-t hits the fan because then you're
like oh my gosh what's happening oh my gosh
going under what's gonna happen to bite
you what's gonna happen to baba and then
it's very hard and that's why that's the reason
why investing is risky is because emotions
are very easy to get you and and you also
buy because of emotions like today again like
forbes contacts me i was like hey bitcoin
reached five fifty five thousand dollars
where do you say i'm like of course well there's
a bullish ticket and people get more excited and
that's the mo that's why the markets go up
and then it's very hard to not go and buy so
yeah the mistake by far is falling for a
higher fomo and not having a strategy so
i combine the well knowing what i'm
investing in with market sentiment analysis
and um i really just it once a month i
don't really look at the markets i don't go
i don't manage my portfolio based on what's
happening in the news i manage my portfolio
every second wednesday of the month and that's
it like that's my schedule i don't care what's
happening in the world so clearly you have
this um traditional financial background
you know you spoke about wall street but
what about crypto then so where did that
come in how did that come into your life so
interesting so i actually heard about bitcoin
in 2011 and one of my friends said hey baby
family there's no way i'm gonna buy bitcoin and um
completely forgot about it and it's so funny that
crypto actually just fell on my laps because first
in 2015 a company in the uk asked me to start
creating crypto content for them use btc and
i was like i don't know anything about it i'm
like just do it you know about forex and about
stocks you probably can figure it out i'm like
all right so i started learning about it i was
like oh my gosh this is so cool that's the first
time i really understood the power of bitcoin
like decentralization all these things and then it
kind of brought home some painful things from my
past bitcoin so again being from iran so a little
backstory is my dad before the iranian revolution
at 1979 that many people may not even remember
anymore my dad was actually successful very
a wealthy person and then once the revolution
came in 1979 this is before i was born the new
islamic regime took over all of us assets froze
his bank accounts they were going to kill him
all the stuff they didn't kill him but they
basically took away everything and when i
learned about the decentralization of
business oh my gosh if you had bitcoin
yeah the government couldn't freeze this bitcoin
like there is no way the government can access it
and that is that like really hit home for me it
was okay so this is something that i want to get
more into and then because i was creating content
for news btc and then i was also getting content
for crypto briefing then the four dummies while
these four gummies asked me to write the book for
them right all right so it kind of fell on my laps
uh that was i would say it was kind of lucky that
i got into it very lucky for sure and i've become
a fan and an investor in the field ever since
it's still the same idea again isn't it you have
to be personally affected by something in order to
really um understand it um i find that really
fascinating for me i totally agree with you
that is what struck me about bitcoin the fact
that it's immune from a government control
corruption you know whatever it is and you
know you're truly suffering of your assets if
one day tyranny comes um so it makes sense
so does that mean that you are bitcoin only
or because this space can be very tribal you know
people get very emotional about these things so
are you bitcoin only or um tell me what else
do you hold what else do you see value in
i'm not bitcoin only so i treat my crypto
portfolio the way i treat my soft portfolio i
believe in diversification i'm a value investor at
heart i know value investing is warren buffett's
thing and i understand that warren buffett is not
into crypto but i think it's just because he's
too old and i think it's good because he doesn't
understand he shouldn't get into it but i apply
his method to crypto so i do diversify i again
so it's a little bit harder with crypto because
you cannot like become a cust consumer or customer
of ethereum like yeah you can get into the thing i
mean i don't want to become a goal like getting
to their networks and start mining and become
a network but i try to understand as much as
possible about their methodology and so how i
um diversify my crypto portfolio is actually
category based because obviously there are
different cryptocurrency assets for different
purposes optimize for payments optimize for
platform optimize for privacy onto optimize for
whatever and then so um and then i kind of pick
the category king of that category as my crypto of
choice so bitcoin for me is gold 2.0 so instead of
investing in gold i invest in bitcoin and then you
know i invest in ethereum i do invest in cardano
and the way i learned about them well it was again
i was fortunate enough to be able to actually
interview uh charles huskinson an interview like
the people who are really really familiar with
the different uh crypto projects i'm gonna get
a little bit hated but um but i did interview
who's this who is the founder of bitcoin cash i
forgot he used to live in japan oh roger that yeah
great guy we have a lot of smoking with him he's
great yeah he's a great guy a lot in common lives
in japan we bond over partying with punky but
it kind of made me not want to actually invest
in between cash so uh i'm gonna head here but um
that that's how i really went around the fact so
with stocks is easier because you can't
actually go and become a consumer but
with crypto you actually have to go and learn and
so the learning curve is a little bit harder so
not bitcoin is there is there a particular coin
you're specifically bullish on so bitcoin2 is gold
2.0 but a lot of people talk about ethereum being
um internet 2.0 um so how do you is there anything
you're particularly bullish on right now yeah so
i'm sorry i certainly have ethereum cordano um
my boy bitchboy uh kind of talked me to abe
um but some of the the the cryptocurrencies
that i like their mission are chain link and uh
yes the channeling is the one that i actually
really like their mission and actually i haven't
checked my crypto portfolio but these are the few
like which one which others are but these
are the few that um i've been investing in
i use it i'd love to get your uh yeah say that
again xrp and uh now i just feel like they have
lost their competitive advantage and so that's
why i'm not as bullish on that very interesting
um yeah link is what link is one i hold as well
i'm pretty bullish on that i'm very interested
in what's going on with solana and different
ethereum competitors um so no i i'm totally
with you but i'd love to hear your opinion on the
market right now you know we we've seen a lot of
weird action you know whether it's starting
with elon musk in the energy fund when it
comes and then china banning it not banning it
banning it not banning it um pullbacks or 50
but things seem to be up right now you know um
highest we've been in a long time and looking at
the number now it's about 55.3 k um so what's
your thoughts on the markets right now do you
think we could potentially go into new highs
or where you're at oh okay i'm not joking that
i don't listen to the news like i don't know
what's happening okay so forbes just asked me
to comment on what i see i just looked at the
chart i'm like okay this is what's happening
to me bitcoin has value because bitcoin has finite
amount of bitcoin that can ever be like to me it's
like no-brainers like supply and demand there's
limited supply and no matter if china is going
to ban it or not ban it or whatever is going to
happen bitcoin is gonna have value it has a brand
recognition i think it takes all the points for
me so i don't care what china is doing i don't
care what my says uh but i mean from a technical
point of view obviously bitcoin because it's a
very valid volatile asset uh it looks like uh
it has it definitely has broken above the hmfa
cloud which is an indicator that i look at
has completed a double bottom chart pattern
we have bullish signs but it also has exhausted
the most recent bullish um sentiment in the past
four days and so we could see a little bit of a
pullback towards either 52 or 48 and then yeah we
we are in a new bullish cycle so i wouldn't
be surprised if we see 58 and 65 and beyond
uh being reached and uh okay well yeah i mean
i think it's great that you don't listen to the
news um because you know it results in a lot
of panic selling and a lot of fun and a lot of
concern um but no i'm also very excited to see
what happens i'm also quite hopeful and um quite
bullish on the fact that we could actually
get back up to 60 um before the end of q4 um
because i was hoping to make enough money this
order to invest even more at lower prices in
bitcoin and then it went up before i would i
got to invest at lower prices like ah darn it
because there is no doubt in my mind
that bitcoin is going to reach 100k
but i was really reach 100k like three
years so i can invest more but um
yeah i just created hype by saying that and it's
probably it's not gonna happen so i think that's
what we all want we all want you know enough time
to keep stacking and keep buying more bitcoin
but you know i don't think he can ever hold
enough bitcoin that's sort of the way i look at it
um but you know financial literacy is obviously
very very important um you know just building
that long-lasting generational wealth um
but unfortunately it's not taught in schools
um i do believe we would see a very different
reality if it was taught in school so you know
do you have any thoughts on why it isn't taught in
schools and do you think one day it might be it is
not taught in any schools anywhere in the world
as far as i'm concerned it's not taught in iran
it's not in japan and it is clearly not taught in
the u.s there's really a lot of different reasons
as to why it probably isn't i'm not actually
going to get into it but um i'm very pleased to
see that people thanks to the internet people are
seeing the value of becoming financially literate
i feel like they're more financially literate
people now than ever before in the past decades
and i'm very very pleased to see that and
people are seeing the value of self-education
and that yeah for whatever reason they don't
teach these things at school and uh it all also
it comes back to having your own business and
multiple revenue streams so all right you know
what i know it they want you to become the workers
they want to have the workers and that's what they
don't teach you about entrepreneurship
the teacher about financial literacy
uh they show you this thing and care things
like hey go get go to college and in college
don't teach all the things so everything that i
know today all the money that i've ever made is
thanks to self-education so that's why i mean here
i have like the two comical award i don't know if
you guys can see it i remember i had my electrical
engineering master's degree over here and i
removed it because it never made me any money and
then self-education me all this money and so yeah
educate yourself people it's funny as well because
like it's free generally speaking or it's not
that expensive you know youtube is free um you
know this conversation we're having is free um
so but yeah it is about creating workers um like
i said we'd have a very very different um society
you know um but you you're also not just about you
know having that money mindset but also about um
just a growth mindset in terms of like positivity
and things like that so how do you stay motivated
how do i say motivated so um well again
so i'm i feel like i am oh i am positive
but i'm also depressed at times so
let me see so mind blown yeah wait
i'll just stay on that point i just want
to say on that point though i think every
obviously i just wanted to say i think every
single person who has a growth mindset replies
with that exact response which i thought was
very funny but go on sorry that's funny i didn't
know that but for me my epiphany on how to really
monitor my emotions came after watching the secret
so that was my very first you know being mindful
of my emotions and like going after like actually
i didn't know that like always because my mom was
like a warrior she was always worrying and like
always imagining the worst case scenario
and i thought that's the way to live
and then i watched the scene i was like oh
my gosh like my mom is literally just like
attracting all the stress and negativity
and the illnesses that was coming our way
and uh so if somebody doesn't know that they
they will like use their imagination to to
that and so that was the very first thing
that opened my eyes into the importance of
regulating your mind and what you're imagining
and then from there i have it has been a work
in progress i have had coaches i've hired mindset
coaches and the more i invest in myself the more i
journal the more i do my gratitude and
all the things it actually does help so
there are times that i'm unmotivated or
demotivated which with the right word is or
feeling like a failure or feeling like
okay well so now what okay i accomplished
this now why or what is it even for so you can you
can get go down that rabbit hole and then for me
um it has been like you know having coaches
or reading a book that or you know sometimes
like even it's an instagram post was like
oh yeah okay i have to get back to that so
it is all available to us for free which is
just super crazy just surrounding yourself
then with the correct information having that
healthy relationship with social media um no i'm
totally with you i'm also very much about keeping
my social media clean and making sure that i only
have good healthy things coming through um but
you've also grown an amazing audience on tick
tock um which is absolutely incredible so well
done you know huge congrats it your your views
and your content is so brilliant um but you i
watched a video of yours which really struck me
um i thought it was really funny and i i want
to ask you about it so you said that um you've
done everything that you wanted with your career
obviously there's always more to do but you were
sort of happy at a point and then you said now i
want to look for a husband and you said i'm going
to give myself three months to manifest a husband
and then you were like and i did it i have to ask
you about this can you tell me why oh man oh
yeah you watched that six times yeah so i guess
on that one uh yeah it's true i'm i like
these are all the secret like right so i um
so okay i got fired from my job and my boyfriend
at the time dumped me and then i didn't have money
to pay rent so i went that i went back down that
rock bottom and then i switched my mindset again
and then i started working now one thing at the
time like okay i'm gonna become an entrepreneur
i'm gonna like write a book i'm gonna do all
these things and then i was like okay i'm
too hard-broken to actually go back on the dating
scenes i'm just going to focus on this one element
and i promise myself i'm not going to go on a
date while i'm doing it and then once the book
was published my first book we're talking about
um i was like okay now i'm going to go on dates
all right now i have a husband and then it's just
the same principle applied to relationships so i
had this jingle that i had written about exactly
who i wanted to be i like what personality how i
wanted to make me feel uh clearly i didn't think
about all the negative stuff which then came
like when you get married you know but um
all the so when he appeared and then so it's
not about just visual thinking obviously you have
to take actions i took action i went on 400 dates
in three months um yeah 400 days in three months
400 first dates so for 400 uh coffee dates i was
last dates yeah yeah yeah so and then so i got
to meet a lot of people it's just a numbers game
day and then clarity who we want to meet and
then not giving up right so a lot of people
go on one day and they're like oh my gosh
it was so exhausting and the guy was this
and then they start focusing on how shitty i'm
sorry i just cursed but that the date was and
then to get motivated to go on a date again but
i just tried to look at the positive and like
okay this is not working okay you suck at a
husband as a husband but you have this network so
tell me about your network right let's do business
instead so that was the game plan and then it
was funny because when my husband showed up now
husband showed up i was not interested in meeting
him i did not like his profile on tinder oh i
wasn't in there by the way i did not like okay
who's this loser who's coming from connecticut to
meet me in new york city i'm like okay whatever
i'll meet with you i don't have any other dates
on that day i didn't even put on makeup and then
it's funny because in person you actually look
better and then when we got into conversation
oh gosh like he's super cool and then yeah we got
engaged we could spend six months and then we got
marian married within nine months it's been seven
years now wow i love that story it's really the
one which struck me i've seen practically all of
your tech talks um but that's the one that really
the one that stayed with me and then my
husband is my biggest accomplishment come on
no it's great i think it's lovely no i think
it's wonderful why not i think i think it's great
um so i also want to talk about like time
management um because you know you do so
much you have a family you're working you're
writing books um which you know we can talk
about but how do you manage all of that so
um okay some things gotta give at some time
at some point so um either money or time
right so when i didn't have money to spend on
getting back my time yeah i was not
working on my relationship i was
not even ready to have a baby um so you so what
i've noticed what i've learned is the power of no
i learned this from marie forleo and it's super
important like understanding what is the one thing
so what is your goal so have clear goals and then
think about what is the thing what are the things
that are going to move the needle the most towards
your goal and then get rid of everything else
as appealing as they sound and as you grow as my
business grows like these decisions are becoming
more and more like they're not going away like
before i have to make a decision between like okay
like my daughter my husband and my business i'll
in my portfolio but now my business has all these
arms i have 15 people to manage and i have all
these opportunities i have to go to the on this
interview on that interview listen like
all these things all these shiny objects
that uh i sometimes get excited and it's funny
because it actually literally just happened last
week um i i went to fun hike a lot i don't know
if people know about it and it was it's not an
entrepreneurship event and i was a speaker
there and then you get to match my with all
these people and get excited about all these new
things that you can do if you have a software
you can have this and you can have that all these
things and i caught myself and just getting over
overly excited and wanting to do all these
things and then i started okay like it's time
to delegate or get rid of stuff so how i
manage my money my time at this point is
really identifying the one the things that as
i said move the needle towards my goal whether
it's for my business or for my relationship uh
or with like time with my with my daughter so
um what are the things that i can do that are the
most important and then get rid of everything else
so yeah okay the relationship example now because
i talked about business quite well so i noticed
so when i was really focused on my business i
was neglecting my relationship with my husband
and then once um i achieved the goal that i had
in my mind which was like making a million dollars
i was like okay now it's time to focus on the
relationship and then i invested in a coach in
a relationship coach and we've been taking the
class and now we're like okay we have we have
to have a date night every week so no matter
what happens like that is the one thing that
i am no matter what happens gonna make time
for um so and then i it makes the decision
making easier than whatever that happens
on that day i'll just say no to right so
okay so it's a roller coaster so it's so so so
so really it's like a roller coaster and it's
prioritizing whatever your priority is and
sometimes you have to say no and like you said
you you know you've got employees now so it's
not just you running the business um but you've
written a bunch of books so can you tell me about
these books um tell the audience about the books
and you know what they can expect from them yeah
absolutely so the books that i'm the most proud
of are actually just two i mean i've written five
books but the ones that i think everybody needs to
read one is cryptocurrency listing for dummies
so i should i think everybody needs to read it
i think i did a wrong job on that one because
i break down not just cryptocurrencies but like
really the strategy behind creating portfolio with
crypto and if you want to hit with other things
and um i really spill everything in that book and
then the second one is a book that hasn't been
published yet it's this one and so we actually did
a soft launch i felt like a live that last week
um and this one i talk about the generation
involved which is like not just investing in
but just but also entrepreneurship this one is
going to get launched in january so get excited
that is very exciting so yeah in january where can
people buy it so january 9th this is gonna go live
everywhere so stay tuned we're gonna so yeah so
amazon bookshops just everywhere yeah barnes noble
amazon all the place all over and remind us what
what's it called i can't fully read it what does
it say it's called million dollar family secrets
uh it is not published yet so don't go looking
for it it's not there's no place to be found but
it's an actual book million dollar family secrets
how i it's a great cover i love it yeah thank
you oh um fun fact i wrote this book in two days
two days wow how did you do that how did you how
did you do that that was like we came up so we
knew that i wanted to write the book but then the
fun like live speaking opportunity came along was
like i really want to give the book as a gift to
the 10 000 audience and we it was a month before
the the event and it was like okay how are we
going to make this happen and i called one of the
publishers that my ceo recommended and she's like
it's not going to happen you cannot publish a book
in a month especially when you don't have anything
and then i'm like okay what i can't do tell me how
so that's a very key question how can we
make it happen okay first of all go um
call the publishing printer and see how long they
need for it to be published and shipped to florida
so we call them this okay we need three weeks
i'm like okay so we need three weeks so that
means that gives us just one week and then
the editor is like okay i need a week to edit
it that means you need to give this to me on
monday we are on the phone on friday okay and
so i mean it is a little bit misleading
because i already had the content in mind
i knew exactly what i was going to talk about i
have you know this is basically one of my courses
so we had the content so when i say i wrote in
two books two weeks like it it didn't just like
hey let's come up with a concept i knew exactly
what's going to be a four but um like putting
it together and making it into a readable actual
book that gives you results um that was two days
that's impressive um and i think i think you
actually did that in the smartest way possible
take what you already have and if you have as
a course and you have these ideas in your head
and you know put it down on paper and sell
something else get that passive income um i
think that's great i can't wait to read it so i
will be keeping my eyes open for january um so
where can people follow you um you know
just just plug yourself at this point
oh plug in so my i don't have any followers almost
on twitter so please follow me on twitter but uh
yeah i'm on tick tock at kiana danielle there are
a lot of impersonators there so please be aware
i'm not verified on tick tock so that makes
it a little bit difficult on instagram i'm
verified so it's at invest diva and you know
what the bus should just go on our website all
the social media is plugged in there so just
go to investiva.com everything's there guys
please follow kiana she is so incredible
um you know such a breath of fresh air um
you know i think all of your financial advice
is absolutely spot on i love following all of
your content so i want to thank you so much for
coming on it's been such a pleasure to have you
thank you so much for having me it was really
fun absolutely and guys thank you so much for
tuning in and don't forget to join us again
next week for another brilliant guess bye-bye